INSTRUCTOR: Hi there,
2,100 students.
It is now time to use your
SQL knowledge with your Python
knowledge and write Python
programs that will go and run
SQL queries for you.
So that sounds a little
bit intimidating,
but I promise it's not too bad.
We're going to go through
the ins and outs of this
and compare it to things
that we've done in the past,
so that it becomes really
easy for you to understand.
So as a reminder lists
that we've talked about
assigns a variable,
a set of elements.
These can be strings
floats, integers, et cetera.
We can edit lists.
We can append lists.
We can slice lists.
We can replace lists.
Now, tuples are similar
to lists and are
used to store multiple
items in a single variable.
They are ordered
and unchangeable.
Now, the record the
individual record
is going to be returned
to us as a tuple when
we query our database.
So imagine a database record,
that horizontal line of data,
say you're about one
customer, all of that's
going to be contained
within a tuple.
So a tuple instead of having
a bracket has parentheses
and it is not editable.
All right.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
All right.
So now what we're going
to do is we're going
to jump into these examples.
So this will not be submitted.
These are just our examples.
You'll notice here I have
some directions regarding
Python and SQL.
We're going to come back
to that in just a moment.
But let's first off,
we're going to create
a tuple called Seasons.
And then we're going to add all
of the seasons Utah experiences
in this list.
And then output each of the
seasons on a separate line.
All right.
So I should say here
all of the seasons
Utah experiences to this tuple.
All right, there we go.
So as a reminder tuples
will look a lot like lists.
Instead, we just say you
know seasons equal to.
And then we have parentheses
surrounding the tuple, not
square brackets like lists.
So we're going to
say creating a tuple.
In this seasons, let's say that
we have winter, Utah experiences
winter, fake spring.
[LAUGHS] Sometimes we
have really harsh snow.
And then we have this
nice week of like,
oh my goodness, spring's coming.
And then it's back to winter.
Let's see here we have summer.
And then a glimpse of fall.
Sometimes falls a little longer.
All right.
We'll see here.
So now let's go
ahead and run this.
Now, if I was to run this
right now, all it does
is just creates
my seasons tuple.
It doesn't output
anything to me.
All it does is just
create that tuple.
So if I need to output each of
the seasons on a separate line,
then instead of just saying
print, let me just try this.
I'm going to say Print seasons.
This is going to print seasons,
the whole tuple on one line.
Now, if I want each
of them printed
on its own separate line,
I'm going to use a for loop.
And I'll say for y
in seasons, print y.
As a reminder, what this
does is the first value
of winter in the
seasons tuple is
assigned to be the value of y.
Then we print y.
The second value, fake spring
is assigned to be the value of y
And then we print y.
So we do that through each of
the instances in the tuple.
So go ahead and run this.
So now we get
winter fake spring,
summer, and glimpse
of fall all outputting
each on their own individual
lines by using a for loop
referencing my seasons tuple.
Now, we're going to
add another season.
There is another one right
to this season's tuple above.
Now, if I was to try
and add this here,
this is actually
a trick question.
I cannot add anything to tuples.
Tuples are uneditable
so this is not possible.
Now, could I convert this
tuple into a list then edit it?
Yeah, we could do
something like that.
But as far as just to add a
value directly to a tuple,
we cannot do that.
We can do that with lists.
When we use that append method.
All right.
So now that you have a little
bit of experience with a tuple,
I want to show you the
Python and SQL connection.
So this makes Python
significantly more powerful.
You can now access
a large amounts
of data stored in a database.
We will use the SQLite3
which is a module,
is a set of functions,
classes or variables
defined and implemented.
So again Python is extensible.
It's expandable.
Basically these modules bring
in additional functionalities
of Python that somebody
else has created
and you can then
import it as a module.
So the SELECT
statement as a reminder
when I'm writing
an SQL query these
are my six different clauses.
And now we're going to write
an SQL query in Python.
Now, there's a few things
for you to note here.
A couple of things, we can
actually download a database
as a database file.
So here, if you
take a look at this,
the overland SQL-lite database
which you'll see linked up
above, this is the database
file that basically we've
downloaded from SQL Server.
Just as this file that still
contains all of my data,
all of the tables, all of that.
But I can just
reference it as a file.
So we're going to
just reference,
this database as a file
instead of hitting the server.
A couple of reasons
for this, A, it's
oftentimes it can be a pain
to connect to the server,
and so we just want to eliminate
any of those types of issues
in this class.
And it's going to be
the same foundationally
as connecting to the file
as connecting to the server.
So if you want to do this
in your next internship,
all you do is change
the connection string.
And it's the same thing, we're
just accessing it via file.
So you're learning
all the skills,
all the techniques, just
the connections, just a bit
different, and that's great.
So what we're going
to do is you'll notice
that you're going to open.
You're going to click
on Files over here.
And then you're going to upload
the overland SQLite database
into this Colab notebook.
Now you'll notice that
ensure that your files are
saved elsewhere.
This runtimes files
will be deleted when
this runtime is terminated.
So once it's your Colab
notebook has sat for some time.
The runtime has timed
out, if you will.
You will need to re-upload
the overland SQLite.
If you ever get an error that
says like guest table does not
exist, if you're trying
to query the guest table,
re-upload your file
and that will fix it.
So in that files
we're uploading this.
And then we're in
our Python program.
We're going to import the
SQLite3 and reference,
this file.
So this connection is
what I'm talking about.
This would change if you were
connecting directly to a server.
We're just going to connect
directly to this file.
So let's come down
here I'm going
to paste this connection code.
You need this connection
code every time
you try and connect
to our database.
So we're going to
run a query now
that outputs the
first and last names.
All guests between
the ages of 18 and 25.
We're going to output
each guest information
to the screen
separated by commas
and not contained
within those brackets.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So I'm going to once I
do this I've basically
connected to the database.
And now I need to
create a cursor.
So I'm going to
create my cursor.
A cursor is what's
going to go and run--
oh, cursor.
Sorry, cursor equals
connection dot cursor.
So I am using this
connection up here,
and I am creating a cursor
from that connection.
And this cursor is going
to go and run the SQL query
and bring back the query
results to my program.
All right.
So once I have
created that cursor
I'm then going to
tell the cursor
to go and execute a query.
And I'm going to say,
I'm going to write an SQL
query just like I have in
beekeeper a ton of times.
I'm going to say, you know
what, go to the database
and run a query that outputs
the first and last names
of all guests between
the ages of 18 and 25.
So I'll say go and
run this query.
Select first name,
last name, age.
And we're going
to say from guest
where age between 18 and 25.
So I'm going to go and run
that cursor or run this query.
Then once that query
has ran for me--
I'm going to exit out of there.
Then once this
query runs, then I
need to basically grab
everything from that cursor.
So I'm going to fetch all
the records from the cursor.
And I'm going to do
this by declaring
a variable called results.
And basically, it's
going to I'm going
to say results equals
cursor dot fetch all.
What this means is
I want this cursor,
I want to fetch everything.
Basically grab everything
from that cursor
and assign it to be
the results variable.
When I say everything
from that cursor,
I mean all of my
database records
that were returned to me
based upon this query.
So once I say fetch all,
then I'm going to again,
assign it to be results.
And then let's
just print results.
Let's just run this
and see what happens.
So what we notice here
is that every record,
it's being returned to me.
You'll notice that this is a
record in my database table.
So this is a guest,
Arlo Owens is 21,
so they are between 18 and 21.
And their whole
record, that line
of for their information in the
database table, their record,
contains Arlo Owens 21.
And it's within
those parentheses.
There's a tuple there.
This tuple is, again,
a database record.
Then you'll notice that it's
all contained within this list.
So all of these records are
contained within these lists.
So in order to print
out everything,
one record at a time,
I'm going to do something
that I've done
before, which is I'm
going to use a for loop, I'm
going to say for y or for x
in results print x.
So now when I run
this, I see here
that I have every
record outputting
to me one on each line.
And each record is a tuple.
So Hannah Clay 18.
Hannah Clay is a guest.
This is their information
and it's all in a tuple form.
So every one of these is a
record in my database table.
So what we did here
is we told my cursor
to go and run this query.
Then we assign the
results of that query.
We created this variable called
results, which is basically
a list that holds all
of the records that
were returned to my cursor.
Then I print this.
The reason we use this
fetch all is if you ever
have to refer to the cursor more
than once, it can, in a program,
it can actually, basically
removes all of the data
from the cursor.
So instead, we just store it
as a variable called results
for the duration of our program.
So then I can still refer
back to the results.
So there you have it.
We wrote an SQL query
in our Python program.
Pretty cool.
I hope--